[Applause]
let's keep it short and sweet
what scare
two moms or two dads
two dads yeah it's not even close yeah
girls aren't gay yeah
unless one of his two butch moms not gay
cargo shorts
okay two butch mobs versus two
flamboyant gay dudes i think women trade
gay for company
wait what like i said i think sometimes
women trade gay for company
like they'll just be like or trade in
their their heterosexuality just for
company okay you know so it's like i
the majority of your day is not [ __ ]
yeah
but it might be you know hanging out
with somebody being with them enjoying
that time and then the commitment to
[ __ ]
a girl
yeah
it's not that much investment right
yeah when does it end whenever yeah like
it's like the whole thing is for the
girls penetration
yeah you can do sex on a timer just be
like yo it's not invasive sex let's do
three minutes of sex that's fine it is
what it is it's not invasive like you
have to deal with family scrutiny maybe
but like
maybe you're already dealing with this
you're like who gives a [ __ ] now with
that being said yeah which would you
rather have two moms or two dads
oh wow that's tricky
honestly
yeah please
please
i might go two dads
because i'm thinking two lesbian moms
raising me i'm like
i don't know i feel like as a guy i want
two dads
i would want one butch mom because she's
gonna overcompensate and be like big on
me watching sports with me and all that
other bad [ __ ] yeah you play catch with
them he's gonna overcompensate as what a
woman thinks a man is
fire i'd rather get raised by a man
even if he's super flamboyant
i'm like all right
at least he's still a dude you know what
i mean
i disagree
butch mom regular lesbian
yeah i'm thinking two moms
yeah thinking two moms it'd be so loving
it'd be so loving at home dude so caring
two butch lesbians you'd think that's
gonna be more loving than two flames
babies will break the toughest dyke
breaking them bro
also two dads they adopted that kid they
picked one out they wanted him yeah
whereas like two moms like she just one
was a surrogate they had to pick which
one it's the whole thing yeah but gay
dudes don't want to raise kids they want
to be doing meth and sucking cocking
like
[ __ ] dungeons and [ __ ] you know what
i mean like that's where their brains
are whereas like lesbians just to like
they do that's their passion
that's their passion dude
there's an underground space where they
could suck [ __ ] and do meth or ketamine
that's where they would do it like but
lesbians they want to like you know
cohabitate they want to be around their
cohabitators watch [ __ ] shows
together like yeah you know just grow
old to get i think it will work better i
do think it'll work better well yeah i
agree i don't know if they'll make it i
don't know i think they're lesbians i
think they could be like fast fast
lovers
and then like break up quick but if it
was like a real strong lesbian couple
like one of them old-timey lesbian
couples like forever like maybe they
start
yeah like they started a time where they
had to just be homies and then it became
okay to be gay yeah but before that they
were just homies yeah they made it
through all that oprah and gayle you
wanna oprah there we go that's what you
want i honestly think so i think the
household stable with more stable you
want your dad's going out date night
coming back [ __ ] like all these
different colored lipsticks on their
dicks
they're going to [ __ ] rainbow park
you're hearing them
can you imagine you catching
parents [ __ ] yeah you never seen your
dad's dick dog i'm gonna see double dad
dick dude that's crazy
that's crazy and neither of those dicks
are you you're adopted yeah
so now you're just seeing stranger dicks
that's just me and my homies kicking it
like that's just me and two guys
i guess yeah we're just hanging out no i
don't know me whereas you got to be the
man of the house
dove miles you don't got to worry about
your parents [ __ ] you neither if
you're lesbians what because they don't
like guys but dudes they like guys and
they just raised the perfect one
hey i don't think it would happen and
i'm not saying this is what gay people
do matter of fact i don't think gay
people do this but it could happen
it can't happen with the gays but what
do lesbians have sex with dildos and
they're like hey there's a real dildo in
our house they got ten dildos right here
that's not what i mean get this you know
spider-man in
like i don't think they need you it is
not a bad of a deal
what are you getting your dick sucked by
a girl
imagine this you win some [ __ ]
[ __ ] somebody oh what is that [ __ ]
called catamar ketamine kettle hole
you're in a cable you're in a k hole
imagine your dad's come home they're in
some deep dark k hole and they just
stuff you know stuff in your mouth with
dicks
but that could happen with lesbians no
they don't have dicks and stuff but they
come after the farmer's market and
they're like man we gotta just we gotta
just get a dick in here and you have one
yeah but that's
the side of them
you're [ __ ] a lady ugh yeah but
that's your mom that actually give birth
to you surrogate style yeah that's way
weirder nah that is weirder but she
would never do that number one you're
just back to where you were that's not
even sex a mom wouldn't let's just
rewind yeah yo if you [ __ ] your mom
that's a rewind
[ __ ] your mom
run it back you never want to run it
back feet first
what's that thing called when you come
out feet first breathe
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip you can
get the whole episode at patreon.com
flagrant2 but i gotta tell you how to
get your mental health on point and that
is
with talk space okay now i know it
sounds crazy maybe before the pandemic
that if you were gonna see a therapist
that maybe you see them on zoom or maybe
you just talk to them over the phone
that's ridiculous you're supposed to go
into the office sit in one of those
goofy couches or chairs and tell them
about your feelings well you know what
the pandemic came in and it changed the
way we communicate and now people that
were having uh normal therapy sessions
before the pandemic are all doing their
therapy on zoom or talking over the
phone maybe even texting and that's what
talkspace specializes in and they can
help you i understand there's things in
your life that are troubling you things
in life that are troubling all of us
let's be honest i've been seeing
therapists on or off since i was
probably in third grade i was fortunate
enough to grow up in a household that
was very supportive of mental health and
uh the exploration of your own personal
mental health i think you guys should
check out talkspace they have an app
that puts you in private rooms so just
you and your therapist can talk you can
send messages 24 7 get replies
throughout the day no need to wait for
your weekly appointment talk spaces
encryption and add security features
keep your conversation fully protected
okay so whether you're struggling with
anxiety depression self-doubt anything
else talkspace gives you access to the
help you need to move forward okay so
you can join talk space today and start
moving forward with a single message
just visit talkspace.com and get 100 off
your first month when you use the promo
code flagrant at the sign up that's 100
off at talkspace.com with the promo code
flagrant now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon question okay what do
we got what up flagrant twitch just
wonder what is the hardest drug you've
ever taken and when and what was the
best high or trip you've ever had
i know your answer unless it was burning
man the hardest drug i did
was
oh god
what is the prescription painkiller that
they give you vicodin oxycontin ketamine
propofol uh no no no no it's uh
similar to maybe propofol but it's like
um
fentanyl uh no no no like you're
basically on your deathbed they give it
to you so morphine morphine milk of the
poppy milk of the poppy yeah
no morphine i did i'm pretty sure i was
put on morphine when i had extreme back
pain in college oh [ __ ] i like pulled my
back do you remember you used to pull my
back and i'd be [ __ ] up for like weeks
at a time do you remember this at all
how did you get back pain
i just pulled my back getting it blown
out back blowing up getting that just
blown out my back blown out wait what
how did you hear your back this happens
to me all the time you guys have
probably seen me [ __ ] up like this
there's something with the left side of
my back the muscles are tight or
something like that
that's the same thing okay go
every time my back hurts it's the left
side and like along your spine it's like
on the left inside left side me too guys
in lower lower yeah
oh okay but
problem is for me and i'm sure you do
the same movement and whatever the
movement is
it exacerbates that issue that you have
so i have like this tight left side so
when i would play basketball if i jump
up to block a a shot or jump to get a
rebound really quick it stretches the
muscle and muscle already doesn't
stretch and then it contracts more and
then the next day you feel off i'm done
for a week to two weeks yeah cannot do
anything i can't remove the first time
it happened i was [ __ ] up
and uh i was on that morpheme boy she
was fired it was the best feeling i've
ever had in my life
yeah it felt like i think someone's
describing i don't want to take this you
know uh take credit for it but it was
just like the best hug you've ever
gotten i think people said heroin and
it's basically heroin
and it would it was i felt so warm so
cozy it was just unbelievable oh that's
so great yeah i'm thinking about even
right now yeah yeah so that was the
hardest drug i ever did yeah akash cbd
now i did propofol i was in the hospital
one time they put me on people did the
michael jackson son that [ __ ] was
amazing dude really i was so happy i was
texting everybody i knew how much i
loved him but like also in an honest way
like uh i texted the while and out
thread that i was on like god you guys
are so talented i love y'all so much
they don't pay y'all [ __ ] man y'all
deserve better and i was like i texted
my wife at the girlfriend at the time
you're so sweet i love you so much you
annoy me sometimes but you're the best
dude i love you i was telling everybody
i loved him but also like [ __ ] on
him a little bit you didn't get those
mixed you didn't text your girl like
girl you don't get paid enough
dude it was well i missed the flagrant
episode and i wanted to call in but i
think when i called you guys didn't
answer the time y'all were like
recording right and i wanted to just
[ __ ] be high on the podcast i've been
so funny all right mark what about you
uh i guess heart i don't know what
hardest means like
come on i mean like i've
i've smoked weed drank alcohol and then
did molly once yeah yeah you did molly
one time
mushrooms oh yeah i did half a little
chocolate i didn't feel that at all they
didn't really do anything molly is
pretty hard yeah dude what counts as
hardness though molly
to me it's illegal
uh
well is how illegal is mullet
illegal illegal so i'm sorry it's a
stage what is it like schedule one
schedule one isn't weed also scheduling
i don't know but yeah molly's harder can
you die from it don't die from weed
alcohol i guess you could die from
that's hard yeah but um
i get weird because in my my hardness is
like intensity so like yeah like you do
like coke it's like super intense like
your heart's beating crazy like have you
done coke no but like that's what it
looks like you're like sweating it's
like anxious yeah i don't like you do
other drugs like you trip you just
aren't even on earth anymore yeah dmt
and [ __ ] i'm like oh that i don't know
to me that's hard yeah i remember i
watched one of my childhood like one of
my best friends growing up he got more
and more drugs he had a coke in front of
me and he was like dude you got to try
it it's like instant coffee and i was
like buddy i'll just drink coffee like
what are you talking about you know we
have instant coffee
but yeah i just don't feel like me being
like yo i love all my friends was like
i wouldn't describe that experience as
hard yeah yeah yeah i mean like i love
everyone why is there war like that
wasn't a very uh hard experience dove
dove mushrooms at my wedding no
mushrooms and molly those are happy
drugs it doesn't feel hard right i i
tried acid once
that's good i never thought i'd ever try
it and i did it but i did a super dose
because my friends at the same dose but
they had done it before and when you
know what to expect you can handle it i
didn't know that you truly leave planet
earth and i went to it's like you're in
reality and then all of a sudden you're
in the upside down and it's just
it's either everyone's against you or
it's amazing visuals are insane so if
you try to like close your eyes it's
like get out of what you're seeing in
the real world you're just on this like
you know that cat meme that throws up
like a rainbow
and it lasts it's not a two-hour trip
it's like 10 to 12 hours like you get
exhausted from there but then when i'd
come back in reality like most insane
visuals ever but just uh i would never
do that again unless it was smaller dose
and guided or something but that was
duration sounds too long other than that
it sounds lit it's pretty shroom sound
lit i'm interested in shrooms i almost
did them at your wedding when they had
the little capsule yeah i was like yeah
i don't know if i'm ready yet but i was
like that seems fun yeah he means my
bachelor party yeah but it might happen
at the wedding
yeah i don't know if i would do molly
again anytime soon though
really i'm doing it at the wedding what
are you talking about
why why you were the worst on molly
[ __ ] buzz kill mark over here
well i know this is just a series of
interactions in my brain right now
making me feel good
like over analyzing the joy and love he
was feeling that's how it was everything
that first time i ever drank alcohol i
did it in with like milliliter droplets
to like measure how much alcohol i was
drinking to know how i was feeling per
like milliliter valve yeah but you just
gotta let it go you're like i know this
is just my synapses i want to be out of
control i want it to be measurable yeah
it freaks me out just let the feelings
feel bro this is where was it that he
did molly at the bachelor party yeah
that's not exactly molly bro
if you're going to do molly let it hit
you on the grass like you really need
that hit me on my ass i was out yeah
eating lasers yeah i was eating lasers
done yeah yeah
did he eat it he tasted it he told me
after he's like bro that laser was
cherry dude
cherry ladies and cherry laser dude it
was sick
it was a cherry haul i remember the next
morning you just said i feel my brain
recovering yeah that was bad if there
was ever an idea for an enemy oh did i
tell you about this when i bumped into
the uh drum player
yeah no somebody else told me you didn't
tell me navadeep i think yeah yeah yeah
navdeep i bumped into him at the amex
lounge in
uh mexico city airport yeah that's so
wild dude and i was so [ __ ]
emotionally and mentally depleted from
the drugs that we've been doing
i didn't know how to hold a conversation
so i walked up to him and i was like hey
man what's going on and uh i was i'm
looking for a drum i don't even see the
drum
i'm like please let this guy be the
[ __ ] dude you need the balls dude
that's bold of you they had no bottles
of water in the amex lounge and i'm like
i'm not about to get sick drinking
[ __ ] tap water right before i leave
next to go [ __ ] that i'm on a flight for
five hours it's the worst amex lounge
that's like trash i'm sweating yeah i'm
sweating i walk up i say hello and him
and his boy who are like really sweet
like start a conversation they're like
so nice and they like stand up now i'm
not in the position to have a
conversation with any human in this
moment like i'm literally falling apart
like like seriously and at one point in
the middle of him talking i just go
yeah i just i just take my head and i
bend it down until
you try to retreat into the turtle shell
say what yeah you're trying to i just
retreated yeah yeah i go yeah all right
i gotta sit back down
i don't have to sit back down that's the
least necessary thing that you ever do
in life is sit down
and i just left the conversation i go do
you guys think they have water here and
then i just went i sat down and they
haven't spoken since you said it was
your bachelor party though right yeah
thank you if you told them it was your
bachelor party they knew what was
happening
they're like oh he's [ __ ] up
i mean it will be traditionally just a
different tradition yeah yeah that would
be sick you should absolutely come in
your garb though i'm doing it that's i
just gotta get uh find a new outfit and
that takes i gotta find time to do that
it could be the same outfit doug i don't
remember what you want yeah i promise
dude and nobody at my wedding remembers
i couldn't wear the [ __ ] i wore at
robbie's wedding for sure yeah but no
sneakers though son
come here some [ __ ] jordans and [ __ ]
come on
i guess you could do that i want people
to express themselves yeah dude it's
burning man for a wedding right kind of
but fancy okay christopher poi his
bougie man
exactly anyway yeah that's a good
question
what's up [ __ ] and i got one question
for y'all if you had to cut off your
meat
to gain one superpower
of your choosing what would it be
to grow a dick back yeah it's yours to
grow a bigger difference
if i could grow a five inch dick that'd
be fine oh that's a great answer bro
[ __ ] what's supervised you grow a dick
oh [ __ ] that's funny one way it's
one superpower but you got to cut off
your dick what's funny is you could just
say if you could have a superpower what
would you want but this guy's like you
got to cut your dick off together you
got it what is that that's got to make
it worth it yeah yeah it's like a life
for a life
remember when he needed that lifestone
and he dropped his [ __ ] yeah from the
balcony yeah he dropped his daughter his
daughter [ __ ] yeah yeah it wasn't even
his daughter everybody made a big deal
about that [ __ ] he stole that [ __ ] when
he killed half her family on his
uh 100 or whatever her planet 100
so it's like
just killer
like i don't understand why that was
such a big deal like i was super
emotional about that i was like yeah i
was crazy about to kill his daughter but
it's not his daughter he just stole her
green [ __ ] yeah right and then
he did right he stole her and then he
killed it so he could get what he wanted
yeah he [ __ ] him up yeah i never
stolen some [ __ ]
and then killed it the life for a light
thing yeah i said that's what i mean
like it's like you're killing sabi what
it's like you killing sabi you stole her
from her family
you wouldn't kill her can i be honest
with you though like cookie
can we talk about what would you kill
your dog that's a great question oh no
no
in order to get
moment of silence from your wife
no i'd be too much crying i couldn't
even get that that's facts that's fact
no what would you kill your daughter
daughter what would you kill your dog in
order to get yo nothing dawg nothing
would you kill your dog i watched a
really [ __ ] up video yesterday on
reddit of a of a dog attacking another
dog just like walking down like the
street of santa monica they're walking
by each other one dog crazy and the one
dog just [ __ ] latches onto this
golden retriever and will not let go and
there's 20 people standing around all
like just sort of doing that bystander
effect of not helping ain't helping
and but the guy who's got the golden
retriever is just like yo get your dog
off and the woman's holding her other
dog just it won't let go it's just
[ __ ] in it's mangled it's blood it's
awful
i would kill the other dog if if i own
the golden i'm absolutely murking that's
why i'm getting a gun bruh somebody
lunges at happy
let's go dude i'm killing your dog if
your dog's hurting mike's
chicken wings
yeah
you were the blaster might be crazy
remember you want to do steroids you
realize you still have to do work
but now you're gonna have the gun that's
the ultimate
first of all i got the steroids they got
confiscated at the border thank you but
you never ran it back you never got it
again no it's not like about to stop you
nah another yo a bigger guy than jordan
talked me out of it i was like
yeah the indian wrestling that's how
that's how you do advice
yeah 100
he said uh don't do it you'll whatever
as soon as you get off you'll lose
whatever gains you make wait he's like
i've done it but jack indian told you
not to get jacked yeah hey it seemed
like it worked out for him that's what
i'm saying this guy's mentioning wwe
champion yeah
he didn't want to convincing when he
said it
he was very he was like dumb but
everything good that happened to him in
his life happened because of steroids
he's got nice titties and abs yeah like
hello no-brainer what up people you just
watched a clip from our weekly patreon
episode you can support the flagrancy
you can support this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
you